When you start building more
complicated user interactions,
you'll come to rely on
animate with duration,
a method used to specify the timing of
a change in the appearance of a view.
Animate with duration
belongs to the class UI view.
UI kits generic view class.
You saw this method earlier
when we discussed extensions.
As promised, I want to return to the
fate extension demo Xcode project, and
dissect the closure expression syntax.
Open the View Controller.swift file and
take a look at the sunrise and
set method.
Focus on the completion parameter.
Do you recognize the closure
expression syntax?
Here you can see that the method fadeout
takes in a closure expression as
a parameter,
the parameter named completion.
And that closure expression takes
in a bool as a parameter, and
returns void or nothing.
The word, in, let's us know that
the body of the closure is coming up.
In the body of the closure we find
the code that is intended to be executed
after the animation is complete.
That's why this closure
expression is called completion.
The body of the closure says.
If the image is set to sunset,
change it to sunrise.
If the image is set to sunrise,
change to sunset.
This call to fade in is also
part of the completion closure.
So what's going on here with
the completion parameter for fade in?
You might think we'd see another closure
expression here, but all we see is nil.
That nil is standing in for
the closure expression.
It's saying, this is what I want to
happen after the image fades in.
I want nothing to happen.
Now let's switch over to the UI
view extensions file for a second.
I know I already pointed this out, but
I want to reiterate that this completion
parameter actually has an optional type.
You can see the type of
the closure expression here.
As we just saw, it takes in a bool and
returns void, but
then notice this question mark.
That question mark makes it possible to
pass in nil as the completion parameter.